sweet guy - nice - everybody just Oh
hugging everybody really had his time of
being like yeah I'm sure there was a
time it's a super dick famous you don't
get that famous at the time when people
are treating you like just a god you
know everywhere he went I mean he the
rock star that was the pinnacle rock
star write a list so a list actor
professional athlete that's the order
but do you think they have to be dicks
no no you think they become dicks but
just because here's my theory about that
is that the the fame that level of Fame
is overwhelming people grab it at you
all the time so you just develop this
Dickey thing just to keep people a [ __ ]
away from me yes like if you get to that
I would imagine like that Michael Jordan
or even Bieber I mean that there's a
level where you can't go anywhere
listen I've been I've been around Bieber
yeah what's it like he's done and I
don't he's never alone because I always
got somebody there but I don't think he
trusts anyone and that level of Fame
where you're just also used to you know
he'd get me a water get the car right I
want to go here or when you get used to
that becomes normal just telling people
just telling people what to do becomes
normal
listen to I was at I was at a party and
he was he was there and he's he's like
playing his music for his new album and
he just looks at me he says hey can you
give me a can you give me a vodka he
says give me a vodka thing and then I
went I was like okay yeah and then when
I gave it to him I thought I should have
said no do the same thing I was at the
Laugh Factory and he was there he was
watching and then scooter who's a buddy
of mine Scooter Braun you know scooter
comes down you know and he says hey yeah
Erica Justin would like to see you and I
at first I was like you you know
something a Walkley you don't summon me
but of course I was like all right let's
go you know I went and they're like and
then I saw him too and I was like I
realized like cuz im a nerd this way I
mean I'm a fan of all types of music so
I think the kids dynamic I think her a
talent I don't think it's a surprise
that he's just famous I don't I mean
people get on him you know just by the
way in defense of Bieber real fast you
can't tell somebody they're great since
they're eight years old right
you can't eight years old you're great
you're great it when he's nine you're
great when he's ten you're great when
he's 11 you're great
let's think about that then that 13 is
probably when he first went well am i
yeah you know and then 15 he was like
I'm not great I am great at 18 oh
[ __ ] great now and then when he
finally says it then that's when
everybody goes whoa bro tone it down
it's too late the monster has already
been let loose lizardy mature right he's
already becoming actual adult and he
probably has no calm left in his body at
any given time he's certain low dude all
day long it's just a recovery time for
him he's got if he tweeted I need some
[ __ ] tonight oh it out of control it
would be like American Idol auditions
would be crazier than that